qui est pour qui est contre la science
est levée
la séance est levée
la séance et le v
bonjour je suis Jimmy pain député de la
deuxième circonscription du Morbihan
circonscription ou doit se bâtir le
premier parc éolien flottant de France
c'est un projet que je soutiens
ardemment mais c'est un projet que je
souhaiterais porter un peu plus au large
des côtes de Bellil alors suivez-moi et
cap à l'ouest
c'est ici au large de Quiberon entre
belle et les grois que doit voir le jour
ce premier parc éolien flottant français
15 éoliennes de 260 mètres de haut qui
produiront 250 mow de quoi fournir de
l'électricité à 450 000 habitants
pour Jimmy pain ces éoliennes sont
essentielles pour l'avenir de la
Bretagne mais il veut qu'elle soit
installée à plus de 22 km des côtes une
obligation qu'il voudrait inscrire dans
la loi pour mieux les faire accepter et
préserver au mieux l'environnement car
en Bretagne les éoliennes sont encore
loin de faire l'unanimité à quelques
jours de l'annonce de l'implantation du
futur parc il est venu prendre le pouls
sur le marché de Saint-Pierre de
Quiberon
moi je pense que c'est un sujet très
important pour la pour la
circonscription parce que c'est le
premier des 50 parcs qu'on doit
construire qui donne nous donner une
certaine forme d'indépendance je pense
qu'on peut arriver quand même à le faire
intelligemment quoi et à essayer de
pousser quand même le plus au large
possible tu vois tout en tout en
vachement les gens alors
exactement
mais j'ai l'impression que il y a pas
beaucoup de dialogues sur le sujet bon
ben on vient voilà tu as fait mon boulot
c'est mon boulot bon allez bon ben bye
bye et puis bon courage et puis au
plaisir alors ouais ouais mais tous ne
sont pas si facile à convaincre les
opposants aux éoliennes l'attendent de
pieds ferme ça va bonjour bonjour ça va
bien ce premier parc entre Groix et
Belle-Île doit être le mieux discuter
possible avec avec l'épaisseur avec les
usagers avec les industriels avec des
associations pour qu'on essaye de
trouver vraiment un emplacement qui
puisse le moins mal satisfaire aux uns
et aux autres donc nous avons fait les
éoliennes flottantes comme pouvant être
éloigné des côtes justement pour
préserver les paysages or là on nous les
met à une vingtaine de kilomètres de
Belline pour nous cette zone est
inadmissible et il faut absolument que
l'État revienne sur cette tout qui nous
met de gagner sera déjà inquiète de
gagner moi je veux être je crois je
crois
l'éolien ça ne vaut rien voilà je
résume-moi
ne vaut rien mais l'éolien maintenant
c'est quasiment c'est quasiment
l'indépendance
c'est les conneries monsieur c'est de la
merde et moi je vais vous expliquer un
peu mais on a une belle criée à Quiberon
qui vend du poisson du poisson du beau
poisson la du turbo et cetera plus ça
c'est terminé
ça donc dans la zone qui avait été
soumise un petit peu au débat public
mais
je crois vraiment que tu es là c'est
vrai tu vois et pourtant ce matin
[Musique]
on ne peut plus
on ne peut plus se passer de ce genre
d'énergie on ne peut plus
[Musique]
cette fois chacun reste campé sur ses
positions
[Applaudissements]
voilà on est d'accord on est d'accord on
est d'accord et fait ce que je peux je
fais ma part
bonjour
le dossier est décidément très sensible
direction Belle-Île où le député se
mobilise avec les élus et les
associations pour repousser les
éoliennes et préserver les paysages
les maires de bangkor de Sauzon et du
palais veulent conserver cette côte
sauvage et rendre le moins visible
possible ces nouvelles giga et éoliennes
regardez-moi comme c'est beau et puis
tout ça en plus ça a été conservateur
littoral ça a été préservé depuis des
années
des décennies toujours en fait
voilà on est pas mal parce qu'on a un
bon panorama parce qu'on est qu'une
poêle là sur le lieu d'implantation ici
devant vous voyez la à 15 km à peu près
la taille d'une tour Eiffel selon
l'alignement en plus on les verra plus
ou moins façon chant industriel
évidemment ça fait mal au cœur ça fait
mal au cœur le consensus il est pas loin
il est un petit peu plus loin c'est tout
ce qu'on demande
et les maires de Belle-Île voudrait que
les éoliennes soient installés au-delà
de la limite des eaux territoriales ils
espèrent que ces éoliennes seront placés
le plus à l'ouest possible de la zone
définie par l'État mais les pêcheurs eux
veulent un autre emplacement dans les
eaux territoriales et le plus à l'Est et
dans ce bras de fer local la ministre
aurait choisi les pêcheurs
dans leur combat les élus ne sont pas
seules les associations
environnementales se battent elles aussi
pour éloigner ses éoliennes
on a de la chance avec le flottant on
peut s'exonérer des fonds et aller bien
plus au large et pourquoi il faut éviter
la zone choisie par la ministre
c'est à dire ça parce que
il est extrêmement riche en biodiversité
voilà merci merci à vous c'est une
énergie d'un point dont on aura besoin
on en est bien conscient mais pas au
prix du sacrifice de ce paysage en nous
ne connaît pas exactement le prix du
sacrifice du paysage vraiment je vous
remercie de porter ça et d'alerter et et
de se dire que la décision n'est pas
prise qui a encore une fois cette loi
qui arrive et que cette loi va
certainement nous permettre de poser
encore un peu mieux le cadre
devant le député les mers ne cachent pas
leur amertume ils ont l'impression que
les dés de ce futur parc sont déjà jetés
et que la partie s'est jouée sans eux
on a rencontré la précédente ministre de
la transition énergétique on a écrit la
première minute on a écrit au Président
de la République permettez-moi de dire
qu'on a toujours pas de réponse donc
voilà donc c'est aussi ça moi je ne
comprends pas cette façon de ne pas nous
considérer parce que ne pas nous
considérer c'est de ne pas considérer la
population et moi je ne veux pas faire
de scandale parce que je ne suis pas
comme ça mais je voudrais qu'on nous
entende
les syndicats
les locaux évidemment
on a bien compris quel rôle on avait oui
et c'est désolant en fait
entre les élus et les pécheurs le
dialogue est rompu même si Jimmy pain
veut croire que leur position ne sont
pas irréconciliables
ils ont été écoutés mais parce que parce
que des pêcheurs sont des gens
importants sont des gens de qui il faut
prendre la vie mais aussi je pense que
c'est important que eux aussi puissent
écouter un petit peu et qu'on fasse
toujours un pas l'un vers l'autre dans
les cartes marines il y a bien une zone
qui était un petit peu validée par tous
et c'est vraiment vers celle-là sur
laquelle je pousse c'est mon rôle de
parlementaire c'est mon rôle d'élus
d'arriver à faire du dialogue à créer du
dialogue et que les uns fassent un pas
vers les autres
pas toujours facile
impossible d'organiser une rencontre
entre le président du comité des pêches
et le député les tensions sont trop
fortes les pêcheurs ne veulent pas
revenir sur la zone qu'ils ont choisi
lors du débat public et visiblement
c'est elle qui tient la corde ça me fait
12 mois souvent un peu sourire parce que
tout le monde veut de l'énergie mais
personne n'est de chez soi puis c'est
bizarre dans ces cas là on les met le
plus loin possible loin des yeux loin du
cœur c'est bien connu mais est-ce que
c'est raisonné et raisonnable on préfère
impacter durablement des pêcheurs que
d'avoir des éoliennes que l'on verra
très loin parce que ils sont quand même
à plus de 20 km
parce que demain potentiellement ma
maison va perdre de sa valeur est-ce que
c'est ça l'intérêt général est-ce que
c'est ça que
défend monsieur le député pas du tout
nous avec des professionnels la
condition a été que la continuité de
l'activité de pêche présente dans cette
zone puisse continuer telle qu'elle est
aujourd'hui on ne peut pas jouer avec la
vie des pêcheurs et de leur famille
ce dossier cache aussi un enjeu
financier la taxe éolienne si le parc
est implanté dans les eaux territoriales
elle les pécheurs toucherait 1,4
millions d'euros chaque année les élus
de Belle-Île préfèrent renoncer à cette
taxe pour ne pas voir c'est nager
nous retrouvons Jimmy pain à
Saint-Nazaire
Emmanuel Macron est venu inaugurer les
premières éoliennes en mer le député et
du voyage sur le bateau il espère
pouvoir défendre sa cause auprès du
président
moi je vais me bagarrer effectivement
toujours pour que des choses simples
comme chercher à éloigner des parcs le
plus loin possible des rivage des
rivages soit fait évidemment si je peux
lui glisser je suis venu encore une fois
avec mes plans du parc Groix à Belle-Île
en voyant bien ces eaux de rocheuses en
voyant bien cette zone qui avait été
validée par le ministre on voyait bien
que dans cette zone il y a vraiment une
part qui est à la fois loin des côtes et
aussi qui est sur une zone où il y a pas
encore de biodiversité donc c'est tout
ça que je vais essayer car tu as la
pluie de lui faire de lui montrer
c'est la dernière chance du député le
dernier espoir pour les élus avant
l'annonce imminente de la localisation
du parc
alors est-ce que vous avez pu parler au
président de votre amendement que vous
souhaitez oui l'amendement encore une
fois mais de cette importance de mais il
en a parlé d'ailleurs dans son discours
l'acceptabilité des champs Élodie en mer
ne se fera pas par la loi il se fera par
la planification et par l'acceptation de
tous et ça j'ai vraiment pris ça comme
un point pour moi
6 jours plus tard à l'Assemblée c'est la
douche froide la déception se lit sur le
visage de Jimmy parent
je viens de recevoir le communiqué de
presse
disant finalement que donc ce parc se
situera dans la partie est de la zone à
plus de 20 km de la pointe du punaise
voilà ce que je vois donc la partie
Yester celle qu'on ne souhaitait pas ça
fait un an et demi que je me que
j'essaye de me faire entendre que que
j'écris que j'allerte que voilà
maintenant écoutez on verra bien comment
les choses vont évoluer moi j'ai fait
mon je crois avoir fait mon boulot quoi
je vais faire mon boulot je vais
continuer à le faire dans la prochaine
loi de simplification énergétique pour
qu'on puisse avoir un discours clair sur
ces par éoliens offshore mais je
regrette qu'on n'est pas soit attendu
que la loi passe soit écouter un petit
peu plus les gens du pays
toucher mais pas couler le député
continue son combat pour faire adopter
son amendement dans la future loi afin
que tous les parc éoliens flottants
soient implantés loin des côtes
convaincre mes collègues parlementaires
c'est ce que je vais essayer de faire
mais hélas
je risque de me servir de cet exemple
comme étant quelque chose à ne pas faire
et j'ai peur sincèrement que que
j'allais dire que la fronde locale mais
que que ce qui va se dire un petit peu
localement ne va pas aider à ces parcs
offshore dont on a besoin pour notre
souveraineté énergétique
cette décision renforcera-t-elle la
fronde anti-éolienne ou au contraire
permettra-t-elle un grand débat sur les
zones d'implantation des éoliennes
flottantes
l'exemple de Belle-Île s'invitera
certainement dans l'hémicycle lors de
l'examen de la loi
[Musique]